merci d'être là on va parler du biopic
sur grégory lemarchal vous attendez
cette séquence depuis le début et bien
sûr à l'antenne à 21h15 on aura pierre
lemarchal au téléphone le père le
grégory mais juste avant c'était que
nous parce que pierre
non mais il n'y a rien blatter j'espère
oui qui vient de me dire que ça twitte
que je suis fatigué des fonds c'est
bourré et des plus démunis messieurs
régimaire pardon je suis et l'asie
mineure ici alors je sais pas s'il faut
être drôle si vous êtes drôles et donc
voila se pose est ce toujours savent que
j'ai non mais depuis un an j'ai parlé
des points d'accès d'alcool et
toxicomanie dès que je fais un petit
truc un peu fou
c'est au coeur des fonds c'est que
l'alcool et la drogue ne donne pas de
talent et c'est ça qui m'a sauvé la vie
c'est parce que pour avoir du talent je
suis obligé de ne pas en prendre
il attend donc et puis si j'ai envie de
faire ça ça veut pas dire que je bois je
sais pas si les fait rire ou pas non
mais et je me suis dit en cas de coup
dur j'ai dessiné mais ce n'est pas drôle
jeudi je mets une jupe et je lui dis moi
et je continuerai une chirurgie c'est
alors c'est la ceinture serrières pierre
merci ça ça veut dire qu'on est bourré
j'aurais dû te faire un truc terre c'est
de faire tu m'a beaucoup touché parce
que sachez que et dur que ça m'a touché
parce que tu es un immense tas à une
carrière incroyable et été très ému de
venir ici et tu avais un petit peu comme
un petit peu d'appréhension
non enfin bien sûr je me suis frotté
avec et amusé le maire avec mathieu
descamps ya plein tout groupe qui sont
sans filtre m'as tu te dire ça peut vous
rejouez tout ça et quand as tu es quand
un mec quand tout le monde est bourré
mais ça va mieux aller
m